die deutsche Energie Politik ist
eigentlich eine Katastrophe für die
Wirtschaft da fehlt der Strom es fehlt
Energie es ist eine Katastrophe auch für
die Bürger die Energiepreis explodieren
es ist aber noch eine Katastrophe für
die Versorgungssicherheit weil eben auch
nicht mehr gewährleistet ist es ist
einfach schlichtweg dumm dass meine ein
Energiestrategie fährt dass man nur auf
Elektrifizierung setzt und vieles anders
aus der Kraft lässt aus Sicht lässt das
kann eigentlich nicht funktionieren man
steigt das eine klimafreundlichen
Kernenergie aus und gleichzeitig sagt
man eben man macht Klimapolitik das geht
alles hinten und vorne nicht auf nur
erneuerbare da fehlen schlichte
Ressourcen in diesem Land und
Deutschland ist ein Wirtschaftsmotor
Deutschland ist ein Exportnation dem
sagen alles tschüss das funktioniert
dann so nicht mehr diese Energiewende
ist auf eine Ideologie basierend und
nicht auf Physik und Ökonomie und das
müsste eigentlich die Tatsachen müssen
entscheiden und nicht Ideologien von
links grüner Seite